all right what up guys welcome to the
just PE things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
um today I am going to be talking
about
um I guess just like what's going to
happen to the future of the network with
the
demonetization um and honestly just some
changes we were really going to be
making anyways
um so about two years ago I started the
pregame and the pregame was a show where
I brought over guests four times a week
to have conversations about
relationships um and honestly
guys I just can't do it anymore I can't
I cannot
argue with only fans models and low IQ
women that are looking to get
offended I don't know how myin does
it I really don't that man qualifies for
sainthood for the amount of patience
that he has nobody will understand the
amount of
patience the amount of patience you have
to have to do this
job now granted it is the best job ever
and it is a lot of fun
but I really see the future of my
channel on Pearl daily not on the
pregame um and the reason that I think
I'm going to do an odd one here or there
but I I decided this for two reasons
number
one I'm just tired I feel like I've
learned what I needed to learn from
interviewing these
chicks um
and I don't know something like changed
over
time
when I was smaller there was a little
bit more of like a genu
genuiness in conversation people used to
have and that was kind of why I loved it
um to be honest like I
really I loved having these like open
honest conversations where we could go
into like topics
um that were kind of taboo I really
liked that um but the bigger I
got the more people just kind of want to
come on for clout to get their 10
seconds of
fame
um they come in like I don't know
something along the way and it's weird
because you get into media and you start
to realize that everyone just
like has an agenda like it's not really
about finding like what what's true you
know and I learned that when I went on
Pierce Morgan well I learned that a
couple times but that was like a lesson
I had to just keep getting hit in the
face with um I learned that a couple
times
because yeah I would like go on and I
would think we're like here to have a
conversation and it would just be like
not every time I went on pierc but um I
don't know you start to realize it's
kind of like it it it started off as
like a
genuiness and I don't know it's just not
the same like as it used to be I guess
um but even outside of that guys I was
going to quit it
anyway um
because now that we're demonetized
they're kind of expensive to put on and
also the number one reason um I have had
like kind of thyroid issues and I think
a lot of it is
do with the Sleep habits that came with
doing the shows
um and now I only do the shows once a
week and my sleep schedule's a lot
better
um and
before you know when I was doing it for
but anyways my point is it just doesn't
really coincide with like what I want to
do in life and like having more of a
life outside of the show so yeah I I
just it's not really what I want to do
in the future I really see Pearl daily
evolving
um and I really want to do I I want to
talk about High Society a little bit and
I want to um kind of do some field trips
with you guys where we go to like the
classy parts of London because you know
London has a level of class that us
Americans just really don't have like
that in most
areas I mean there's something down to
earth about some genes and like being
from the the Midwest don't get me wrong
but I don't know there's something kind
of elegant about certain parts of
England and I kind of want to show you
guys um at some point I actually I want
to sign up for a finishing school and
like I don't know bring you guys along
with me I think it'll be fun um but yeah
so we're we're semi discontinuing the
pregame for
now
um again I just I can't keep up with the
sleep schedule I can't do it guys
um other thing is Troy Francis is going
to oh start a show with the network
semis soon um I know you guys have seen
him here and there so let me know if
there's like videos that you want him to
do we're thinking he's going to do a
call-in show um where men and women can
ask advice on dating cuz he's been a
pickup artist for like 10 years or I
don't know what they call it like a
dating
coach um Christine Nazarene is starting
a channel this week so um essentially
we're going to have four Talent at the
network um we are going to build a
platform and we're in the middle of it
we're building a
platform for I think the last like 20
minutes of pearl daily are going to be
behind a pay wall I hate doing that guys
I hate doing it but um we have to figure
out a way to monetize with the current
issues um which I I was lucky that I
actually saved a good amount of expenses
so we're going to be okay for a couple
of months but we got to figure out like
a long-term plan here so I have a
meeting with YouTube today where they're
going to tell
me U hopefully what what I even said
because to this day all these fake news
reaction channels and especially there's
one I'm not going to say his name I'm
not going to say his name but I saw his
reporting and the OG fans will know who
I'm talking about I saw his reporting on
me this man is the
most
he was
like he was like oh when I did a collab
with
pearl we made sure we ided every
person that's a big liar he's such a
liar no you didn't oh I could tell you
stories but I won't but okay all right I
just that's what I figured out when I
got online that everyone is such a
panderer and it's so crazy because that
Nick fu I think was my biggest lesson
because in Nick Fuentes I saw exactly
who would sell you out for money and who
wouldn't
um yeah I don't know so anyways those
are my updates with the network let me
know what you guys think in the comments
and get yourself some new merch guys we
have whale merch we have women shouldn't
be online merch we have all this
different types of merch you got to go
check it out um I'll put the link in the
description like the video bye guys